le premier ministre la parole et à
monsieur laurent kurth monsieur le
premier ministre
après la passion on va essayer de mettre
un peu de raison
au coeur de cet hémicycle il ya dans le
contexte actuel des questions difficiles
à poser mais qu'il faut poser
il y a dans la police la gendarmerie la
remet et chez les gardiens de prison de
nombreux jeunes français musulmans qui
ont été recrutés parce qu'il en avait
les aptitudes et les qualités
nécessaires
j'aimerais leur dire ici notre confiance
et notre amitié mais il ya aussi cette
infime minorité
aveuglés par les promesses qui sont pour
nous des dérives religieuses promesses
partagé par ailleurs par certains
convertis à l'islam parce que ses quatre
métiers suppose des missions extrêmement
sensible parce qu'il donne accès à des
armes et des informations
parce qu'ils sont au coeur de notre
système de défense civile et militaire
que voudrait savoir si le gouvernement a
entamé une démarche active volontaire
organisé d'identification de ces
personnes avez-vous pris des mesures
pour éviter demain tout problème toute
dérive où tout drame considérez vous
avoir les moyens juridiques pour le
faire monsieur le premier ministre la
presse s'est fait l'écho de
problématiques concernant les formes les
forces de l'ordre
j'ai entendu avec des collègues des
gardiens de prisons nous faire part de
leur désarroi sur le sujet la question
est trop grave pour se livrer à des
polémiques la question être sensible car
blessé des concitoyens qui ne le
mériteraient pas serait insupportable
mais la question est trop importante
pour ne pas être évoquée monsieur le
premier ministre que pouvez vous dire à
la représentation nationale sur cette
question
merci la parole et à monsieur bernard
cazeneuve ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le député vous m'interrogez sur
les dispositions nous avons prises pour
faire face à l'existence de personnes
radicaliser dans des services publics
mais pas seulement là où des dangers
peuvent se présenter comme j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire devant la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale
nous avons décidé de mettre en place
après les attentats du mois de janvier
un dispositif très particulier qui s'est
traduit par la mise en place d'un état
major rassemblant l'ensemble des
services de renseignement et de police
incluant aussi la gendarmerie
directement rattaché à mon cabinet et
qui a une mission et une seule passé en
revue en permanence le listing de
l'ensemble de ceux qui sont radicalisés
et ce dispositif centralisée fait
l'objet d'un examen extrêmement
attentive sur l'autorité des
départements et des préfets de zone de
ces mêmes listing de manière à pouvoir à
tout moment procéder aux investigations
qui vont bien prendre les mesures qui
doivent être prises et assurer un suivi
attentif de chacune de ces personnes par
quoi se traduit cette action par exemple
nous avons constaté à travers cet examen
extrêmement attentive de ce fichier qui
comporte plusieurs milliers de noms que
des individus radicalisés travailler
dans des sociétés sous traitantes dans
le transport aérien dans les grands
aéroports leur agrément d'accès aux
aéroports leur a été immédiatement
retiré sont plusieurs dizaines
d'individus qui se sont vus privés de la
possibilité d'accéder aux plateformes
aéroportuaires
le même dispositif existe dans l'armée
dans la police dans la gendarmerie je
vais prendre l'exemple de la gendarmerie
et de la police nous avons au moment du
recrutement de nos policiers de
gendarmes un dispositif de criblage nous
avons également un dispositif
d'inspection générale qui est déclenchée
lorsqu'il ya des problèmes ce qui permet
d'être dans une attention absolument
vigilante et d'éviter les difficultés
que vous redoutez qui ont inspiré votre
question
merci monsieur